welcome to this video new game against
the ender from the netherlands sexy
double fianchetto I son we have the
quadruple via chat oh honey okay it's
not playing c5 okay on my dog you pry
the center let's see let's see yeah yeah
I suspected that but I wasn't sure how
good it really is i mean i have 95 it's
sort of putting putting this piece on
pre in a way b7 maybe can go d5 why it
should be but that should be nice md5 i
can take you form aha
funny if I take P twangs and D take c5
Bishop b2 Bishop e7 Bishop a one Bishop
ahead I'm a piece up here right takes
Bishop takes g2 Bishop takes g7 Bishop
f1 Bishop fa isn't this just a piece for
a strange situation the quadruple
fianchetto in full effect
I am just a piece up am I not why am i
terribly miss scavenging here just a
piece right
it should be 2 he can try sure I can
take with both actually just a moment
yeah I can take I can take with this
let's get the night back so that it is
not exposed in any way I could have gone
now a queen age three actually this
would have been stronger but okay the
piece is a piece is a piece so not not
try to be to learn to fancy about this
queen maybe just queen am The Queen H
form forcing the Queen trade or getting
the Queen in an attacking position
yeah night g5 you probably had to play
d5 fu moves the green I go 95 tending
Queen f6 okay I can also just take c7
here right really no no reason not to
night g5 and tending 96
okay let's see how to how to do this can
even take h7 why not greene takes 90 a
check check
black forfeits due to this connection
yeah some people are really am tarrano
can just resign it's easy I don't like
it as well but it's relatively easy to
do yeah not much to say I think 94 is
just a lemon I think maybe night 92 was
also possible at okay 95 and yeah he
must play d 5 has simply no other muth
then I thought or care will probably
take and this situation is not entirely
clear I thought that if or is probably
week that's true the term he can play a
five it's not it's not totally totally
clear cut situation it's also not clear
what I should play III maybe but this
also we can sum squares components to
play here wants to play three and five
then 93 and maybe f3 but I mean this is
I like white but it's nothing nothing
nothing great and this is just just just
losing I think just lose this lose this
material quick quit if I wow yeah okay
yeah I could this is you this is even
stronger made and this one okay but it's
it's just a piece what what else to say
here okay thanks for watching